it's a thursday pft pm we're roughly a
week and a half away from the return of
pft live july 20 is when we'll be back
until then i continue to give you
updates on the things happening in the
world of the nfl and also the broader
sports world as it is relevant to how
the nfl is handling the pandemic and the
big news of the day came from the game
day protocol finally hammered out
between the league and the union what
they're doing they're identifying
categories they're reaching agreements
in those categories and then they're
moving on to something else we've seen
the training camp protocol the travel
protocol today what was made available
unofficially to the media
obtained from a source with knowledge of
the situation the
game day protocol the rules that will
apply in the stadium and
again it highlights
the disconnect
between all the steps that will be taken
to keep everyone six feet apart
to keep people in masks to keep areas
properly disinfected and it's all
appropriate and it's all reasonable and
it's all detailed
but
it all collapses onto itself when it's
time to go out onto the field and have
22 guys
press together and it's not as if all 22
were ever pressed together but you at
least have five on four
or maybe five on seven or maybe six on
seven up front
who are blocking in tight quarters jj
watt yesterday said he's got no interest
in wearing the full face shield
underneath his face mask a lot of
players probably feel the same way the
difficulty of breathing when
everything you breathe out is bouncing
off of that shield and coming right back
into your face when you're exerting
yourself
so
every rule they put in place
to me
makes it harder to reconcile what's
ultimately going to happen when it's
time to go out on the field and play
again and they are putting all their
eggs in this basket the idea that for
the guys on the field
transmission of the virus will be much
more difficult than it would be in a
confined space that if someone does get
out there among
the other players
who has the virus who is shedding virus
that is such a lovely
description if you're shedding virus
in that setting the thinking is
it it
and floats away
and it won't be concentrated enough for
someone to get it and i always thought
you know it all it took was one of those
tiny microscopic viral particles in your
nose or your eyes or your your nose or
your eyes or your eyes or your nose
either one but uh
uh that that's what they're that's and
hey i'm no epidemiologist i don't know
they're the ones who have the incentive
to understand how this all works at a
microscopic level
but that's what they're pinning their
hopes on
because
as we get closer and closer
it's
i think as a practical matter harder and
harder to come to the conclusion that
they will be confident that all the
players who are out on the field at any
given time are clean
are negative for the virus and one of
the
sub issues that created a stir today the
idea that after the game no jersey swaps
well when you think about it it makes
sense right why do you want to have any
additional unnecessary encounters once
the game is over you don't need to have
a prayer circle out in the middle of the
field you don't need to have the
handshake between the coaches whether
it's the fist bump or the elbow bump or
they just give each other the finger you
know you stay at least six feet away
and the swap that's part two but it
seems ridiculous when you think about
the fact that they're banning that
ritual
after players have been pressed together
for three hours playing football so it's
just another example of of how
of how goofy it all is and you know
players like richard sherman were
ripping the nfl for this this was
negotiated between the league and the
union
and sherman is on the nflpa executive
committee so the union agreed to this if
the union insisted on jersey swaps being
allowed i guess they they could have
tried to do it but there's no good
argument for it there's really no good
argument for it the point is i think
it just shows how hard it's going to be
to play football and not have
virus transmitted from player to player
once again
the hopes are being pinned on the idea
that in an open air stadium or in a
domed stadium with
active and sufficient ventilation and
apparently there's high
level and high-tech systems in there
aimed at thwarting an aerosol terrorist
attack that they'll be able to keep the
air fresh and keep the air moving and
any virus that may be expelled from the
lungs of an infected player will
dissipate quickly and not infect someone
else we'll see i'll look at it this way
why are they thinking about face shields
if they're so confident that playing in
an open-air setting is going to be any
better than you know being in a room
with a low ceiling we'll find out we're
going to find out in real time because
it's not like they're just going to
throw their hands in the air and say
screw it they're going to try it
they're going to try and see what
happens i think there's going to be a
lot of that let's see what happens as
the season unfolds
one thing that we are still waiting to
see what happens the actual testing
protocols that's one of the things i
noticed when looking through the game
day protocol
there's no specific plan in place for
how players and coaches will be tested
in advance of the game now look i was
led to believe back in may by people who
know what's going on
that there was a great deal of optimism
that by august or september there would
be
rapid response reliable readily
available testing so that basically
you could get your mouth swabbed and
within
a half hour maybe 15 minutes you would
know whether you were positive or
negative in that moment and so fine
perfect
as you show up for the facility on a day
of practice
as you show up for a game whatever the
case may be you do that test you wait 15
minutes or a half hour you wait for the
negative come back and if it's negative
you go in and you're fine and that
minimizes the chance that there will be
people on the field
who have the virus well
i don't think the testing is going to be
at that level it's not going to be at
that capacity
there were bad assumptions potentially
made about how prevalent and how
effective and how reliable and how fast
this testing would be
so
i don't know when they're going to give
that final test that gets evaluated for
the up or down as to whether or not
someone can play
but
you know if it's thursday
friday
and you're negative then
i mean it's got to be done so you get
the results by sunday morning
and if you do it too far in advance
let's say you do it tuesday you get the
results friday well by sunday you may
have it and you may be shedding virus it
creates a very funky timeline and the
question is how often will players be
tested players want to be tested every
day
especially because they're concerned
about false negatives that's a
a separate issue and that's a problem oh
yeah you're fine it's negative oh
actually the person has the virus he's
asymptomatic he's going to shed virus
all over the place once he goes out onto
the field see that that's the problem
here because
even though you will hear
people in the media who have been
downplaying this pandemic from the
get-go and i continue to believe there
will be a special place in hell for
these people who have actively
encouraged folks to not take this
seriously
even though people like that will say
well the death rates are down well okay
that's great
but at the same time that doesn't mean
you want to have it that doesn't mean
you want to go through the illness that
doesn't mean you want to worry about
whether or not you may die and maybe you
emerge from this process after weeks or
months of illness or maybe you have some
long-term problem they still don't know
what kind of long-term issues having the
virus can create for someone's
so just because the death rate is down
doesn't mean we just shrug at the thing
and it's no big deal that's one of the
real concerns and the other thing is
you still don't want it to spread
recklessly
and
without any containment and that's kind
of what's happening now that's why we're
in the
did you really think back in march april
and in early may that by the time we got
to
mid-july
the virus would be doing what some
people wanted to just let it do from the
get-go wash
oh remember that it'll just wash through
well that's what it's doing is washing
through and everybody's getting dirty
and it's jeopardizing our sports it's
jeopardizing our ability to have
football it's jeopardizing
other levels nfl college high school
there's not going to be by all
appearances texas high school football
this year think about how big of a deal
this pandemic has to be to get texas to
pull the plug on high school football
college football who knows what's going
to happen with that big ten only playing
conference games
now look
i i
that's hardly a guarantee that they will
play the conference games but it's an
acknowledgment that this is a year
unlike any other
and when you look at what the ivy league
did on
wednesday deciding to postpone its
football season all sports until the
spring you do have to wonder why aren't
the other
conferences doing that richard
blumenthal the senator from connecticut
was very candid from march to usa today
that it's all about money and it is
the major conferences and the major
schools want the money that goes along
with having these games televised
they're clearly not going to make the
money that they ordinarily would make
from the experience from the ticket
sales on game day but you want the cbs
espn whoever's got the the various
contracts for the various conferences
that money disappears it's going to
wreck budgets and and look that's
that's bad that's not a development and
you don't want to see a bunch of sports
go away and you don't see a bunch of
people get laid off
but this is what happens when you allow
college football to become this billion
dollar machine
and the labor force is unpaid and you
get yourself in a predicament like this
it becomes very awkward to move heaven
and earth to have college football when
the people who are supplying the labor
are not getting paid for it and they are
taking enhanced risks when there isn't a
standard set of rules and regulations
among all the conferences and all the
schools
that was something we talked about not
that long ago notre dame they're being
very careful dotting eyes crossing tees
keeping the virus out of the football
program first week of the season they're
playing arkansas arkansas has got
different standards you're only tested
if you're showing symptoms or if you've
been in close contact with someone who
has it so you may have a bunch of guys
who
actually have the virus and are
asymptomatic and don't know that they've
been in contact with someone who hasn't
you get all those players together and
then all of a sudden the notre dame team
has it so the lack of standards and i
think the inability to have the same
kind of resolve that the nfl has because
the nfl isn't making any bones about it
it's for profit enterprise and the
players get paid and look at the
struggles the nfl's had
i think it becomes even harder to have
college football in this kind of an
environment where
there's a lot of uncertainty
there
is i think even though you'll hear
people say oh it's no big deal don't
worry about it you got a greater chance
of being run over by a taco trucker but
whatever the the examples these
ridiculous [ __ ] well you gotta be more
likely to be polite you're more likely
to be hit by a flying golf club from
judge smails i mean all these yeah but
still
you have a virus that is
running through the population largely
unchecked
it does cause plenty of people to get
sick it does cause some people to die
and if you just allow it to just go free
it will make its way to the vulnerable
that's what you need to be concerned
about that's why there may be some nfl
to opt out guys with families guys with
pregnant wives guys with elderly parents
who live with them who may have health
conditions
players who are older and may have
health conditions you know most of the
college football players i mean you know
they what what chronic health issues do
they have
when you get into your 30s if you're
still playing offensive line and you're
330 pounds yeah and as i've said many
times many people are walking around
with diabetes they don't know it
that held a way to find how you have
diabetes when you get covered 19 and it
makes you grievously ill or kills you oh
yeah by the way the reason that happened
is you had diabetes you didn't know it
if you'd known it maybe maybe you would
have opted out for the year maybe you
would be more careful and you know it
just gets back to everybody
refusing to be as careful as they need
to be i'm astounded when you look around
the world and how other countries are
dealing with this and you know i know
we've got
a segment of the crowd that is that very
die-hard usa usa and it's always great
here and we're always led to believe
that look around
look how other countries have dealt with
it and look at how we're dealing with it
and if there is no football this year
if if college football season is
derailed if nfl season gets started and
then stops
the blame goes
to everyone who failed to take this
seriously and specifically to the people
in the media who encouraged them who
justify them who excused taking it
seriously go get live your lives it's no
big deal it's just the flu you got a
better chance of being run over by a
runaway hippopotamus
that's the attitude that has allowed
this thing to get to the point where
college football season is in grave
danger is there another kind and
for the nfl it just has
kind of a shoot feel to it
like they're trying to put the best
procedures in place
they don't really know
they hope it works
but we'll just find out
all right one last topic let's talk
about something football related the cam
newton contract the details of his
incentives were reported today by
fieldgates of espn.com and it is clear
based upon
the devices in that contract for him to
make the big money the 5 well relatively
speaking the 5.75 million in incentives
the boxes he has to check to make all
those incentives and ultimately to make
the full 7.5 million if he does all
those things
dresses for every game
participates in 90 or more of the
offensive snaps makes it to the playoffs
makes it to the pro bowl becomes the
associated press all-pro quarterback
wins the super bowl plays at least fifty
percent of every game along the way
doesn't get a buy because you need four
playoff games at 50 to get the full
million dollar extra incentive at 250
000 a game i believe or maybe it's 500
000 a game regardless we have the posted
pft that has all the details everything
he has to do
to get to 7.5 million
basically i win the super bowl and he's
going to be
the league mvp and if they win the super
bowl good chance he's the super bowl mvp
and the end result is 7.5 million plus
the ability of the patriots
to use the franchise tag on it
for 20 20 at a minute at a minimum
cam newton's agent don't you say
look at at least at least put applause
in here
that if he gets
seven million
seven and a half six and a half if he
fulfills a certain number of these
incentives you won't tag him next year
because that's the thing if he has the
kind of year that puts him in line for
seven and a half million he'd be the
hottest commodity ever and free agent
you have the defending nfl vp super bowl
champion likely super bowl mvp who's
waltzing in free agency unfettered
instead
franchise tag fully available so look if
they use the franchise tag and gets you
know 27 28 29 million next year although
the salary cap may screw things up given
the pandemic i'd rather have a shot at
the open market and
it just shows how how
little interest there was in cam newton
that that offer was put out there and
cam newton was willing to take it
because
if he does all the things that get him
to seven and a half million it will be
the best return on an investment for a
sports contract
in the history of sports any kind of
sport because the patriots will have
bought a super bowl championship
for seven and a half
million dollars and one last thing about
the patriots offense with cam newton i
was talking to somebody about this today
remember josh mcdaniels drafted tim
tebow
and josh mcdaniels has
a tebow style offense that can be very
effective
running and throwing and if the
quarterback gets the right blocking he's
not going to be in the kind of jeopardy
that he was in
in carolina when he was injured more
often than he should have been it's got
the potential to work now the
relationship between cam newton and josh
mcdaniels has to work and there's some
concern that maybe it's going to take
some effort to get those two on the same
page but the offense itself
the tebow offense that mcdaniels put
together specifically for the he treated
back around to get
back in 2010
it could work
it could work well and when you look at
the hype video that the patriots put on
social media something patriots rarely
ever do when cam newton signing was
official it's clear he's going to be the
start and it's clear they have high
hopes for cam newton to take this team
to the heights that tom brady had taken
them two six times during his 20 years
with the team that's it for this
thursday edition of pft pm we'll do it
again tomorrow to wrap up the week and
then we've got one more week of pftpm
before pft live returns on monday july
20 until then check us out around the
clock of
profitballtalk.com and we will talk to
you again here tomorrow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports